you can also support the work that we do
by going to david pakman.com slash
amazon before you shop on amazon
everything you buy will send us a little
kick back a couple of people buying dash
cams recently through our amazon link
it's crossed my mind at different times
to get a dash cam and i know that a lot
of people say i just seems crazy but
especially here in Boston the driving is
so nuts and there's all sorts of people
crossing in the street where there's no
crosswalk people uh biking with
absolutely nothing reflective at night
that sometimes I almost say to myself
Pat just for like legal protection maybe
I should have one of these dash cams but
I haven't made the jump I don't know if
you've thought about it will just make
sure that if you actually are at fault
for the accident yet you remove that as
quickly as possible oh yeah I would do
the exact same thing police do right
which is oh you want to review the
footage from this questionable incident
yet it just wasn't working that day we
don't know what happened just the hard
drive was cleared and the local memory
was cleared just for the 15 minutes in
question it's really strange officer now
of course I would never do that but some
people in our audience using dash cams
also a bunch of people ordering the book
underground airlines which uh we
interviewed the author of last week Ben
winters very good book I recommend it
glad some people are checking it out
remember david pakman.com slash amazon